we got this story from jalopnik i love
using leftist sources for this stuff
biden warns americans gas prices will
remain high as long as it takes will
continue the pres yes right the
president said gas prices will stay high
to combat putin and russia's war on
ukraine
i love it
i love it he's basically saying don't
vote for me i think it sounds like more
of a threat than a warning
uh biden threatens americans gas prices
will remain high as long as you take
that you want ukraine to win or not now
pay up yeah yeah it's amazing so at a
time when the democrats are desperate to
find someone to run in 2024 because they
don't think joe biden's going to make it
joe biden's giving them all the reason
to try and find someone else to run in
2024. you know here i like the theory
that you know there have been people
that have said that he keeps like giving
calls for help that he doesn't really
want to be doing this and that he's like
you know they won't just let me go eat
ice cream and like he'll like come like
at different like candid moments where
i'll be like they told me to come out
here and say this so i guess i have to
say that this might be him just like you
know please like don't know i don't
wanna yeah everyone's gonna have to pay
higher gas prices will you finally just
replace me can i go sit down somewhere
yeah this is
a blatant honesty i mean the whole as
long as it takes things is political
propaganda but he's basically
acknowledging that it's not gonna come
back down yeah if you remove as long as
it takes this is an axiom this is as
long as the policies that are in place
uh are in place um the gas prices will
remain high um and it's crazy because it
was i believe earlier this month that
biden did correctly acknowledge that
right now the biggest bottleneck at
least in the u.s when it comes to
domestic gas production is at the
refinery level but then he he blamed the
refiners and said oh you're not
producing enough and you're you're
profiting you know you're price gouging
us and then the refiners came out and
said we're at like 96 98 capacity if you
right now uh lessen some of the
environmental restrictions and
regulations on us we could increase
capacity by double digits and if at the
same time you allowed us to build some
new refineries for the first time in
decades while simultaneously reducing
some of these tariffs on the materials
that we need to build the refineries we
could short-term fix it with reduction
of regulations and long-term fix it by
building more refineries but you know
he'd rather say
putin price hike joe biden said when he
was campaigning he's going to transition
us off of fossil fuels
imagine hearing him tell you that
voting for him and then coming out and
being like joe budden doesn't control
the price of gas yeah like dude he told
you he was gonna do this it's like that
pikachu face meme where it's like i'm
gonna make gas prices go up okay gas
prices go up
how did this happen
and and you try and explain to them all
of the reasons some of which are rbs
they're like it's corporate profits that
explains everything suddenly yeah and
i'm like okay break break down for me
the corporate profits thing and they're
like what do you mean like explain to me
how much money they make like i don't
know i just saw a meme on facebook and
i'm like if inflation is through the
roof and the cost to produce oil has
gone up and the cost to drill for oil
has gone up that means their profits
will in increase
to the same percentage point so i'll put
it simply
if you if if you make a hundred dollars
in profit
and it costs you 75 to produce the oil
that's a 25 profit if the costs increase
by 25
and then you increase the cost of fuels
you sell it by 25 it will also look like
your profits went up 25
but you retained the same level of
buying power
these people don't understand that no so
sure maybe you can say but they're still
getting lots of profits that is true
they are still making billions of
dollars but it's also absurd to be like
well they should they should sacrifice
their profits for the sake of joe
biden's energy policy no no look i'll be
i'll be fair and say yeah they probably
should work alongside with the
government to lower prices but we still
can point out joe biden enacted a bunch
of policies specifically to transition
us off of fossil fuels but to be well
and and exactly i mean it's he said i'm
going to do this and it was like okay
good but now what they didn't realize is
transition isn't like
rainbows and unicorns transition means
make this prohibitively expensive so you
have to do this that's what a transition
that's forced by government looks like
as opposed to a market-driven transition
where it is unicorns where it is look at
this new thing that's way better as
opposed to we're going to make this
thing way worse in comparison you see
these uh these flight cancellations yes
you see other stuff oh i don't just see
about them i have been the victim of
them yes we've been too like they
abruptly will change someone's ticket
yeah cancel their flight or or change it
right then we have it like they just
move someone's flight to the next day or
something no that was them doing it yeah
they emailed me and they're like oh yeah
he changed that he just didn't oh okay
okay that's fine that's different no but
there are stories in the press where
people are saying that's happened to me
yeah that they just changed your flight
to a later date or something i have
gotten on an airplane gotten a
notification that the flight had been
canceled what and then just start
getting up because i realize they're
about to announce it to everyone else
too and they've done that before yeah
and we ended up having to say that was
at charlotte airport we ended up having
to stay the night there and like i'm
looking at i'm like no we're on the
we're on the plane and i look in the
doors open i'm like
i'm like we're getting off the plane and
we did and sure enough like as i'm
getting off the plane they're like uh
everyone we have an update and i'm like
yeah the update is this flight is
cancelled see you tomorrow
uh they said it was because of um oh
what did they say they always say
maintenance and that's because of some
kind of thing with the flight insurance
they don't have to pay as much out or
something like that but the reality is
uh i talked to one of the pilots as we
were leaving and they're like yeah we
already went over our hours and they
thought that these other pilots coming
in would be able to do it but they went
over their hours too i talked to a pilot
and he said most pilots are hitting
their limit yeah and so they're just
you know so my question though is
how
where did all the pilots go
like they quit during the vaccine
mandates they were like well i'm not
getting the jab i'm not and for a load
and vaccine mandates
and we were told the media was like
they're not protesting vaccine mandates
everything's fine yeah a bunch will
probably quit my i like the idea that
everybody got raptured better because it
sounds more fun
because
i've been thinking about this because
why are there shortages everywhere where
are people why aren't people working
it's not even maybe it's the vaccine
mandates and and that could be really it
that
most people
just said i'm out i'm not doing it and
now but but where are those people i
mean they got to eat right black market
but but how what are they doing they got
to make money doing something but
they're still not here
so we went out we went to the movies
over labor uh i think it was labor day
and uh there's nobody anywhere and i'm
just like where are the humans where are
the humans so the fun conspiracy theory
it's not really a conspiracy but the fun
joke theory is that the rapture happened
and um all of the people that got
raptured our memories of them was erased
so now we're just sitting here wondering
why all of the stores have labor
shortages why there's no pilots anymore
they're all gone and we just can't
remember where who they were oh good so
i have a new nightmare
thank you for that that's good
you know because james is catholic right
he would have to be raptured and i'm
like i don't know
what if someone found out they were
wrong
no but in all seriousness though
something doesn't make sense i think
they're at home collecting unemployment
but for if they're not this long not for
this they were cancelling flights last
year they were yeah you're not going to
be unemployment for two years for for i
mean we're going on
18 months is that the launch they did
extend it so there is actually an
explanation for this when you pump
trillions of dollars into the economy
and artificially create demand while
simultaneously paying people to do
nothing you create a bunch of consumers
and reduce the number of producers and
we're watching that play out in real
time the way that corrects is through a
massive recession which is coming if it
hasn't already started it's coming and
it is the reality of when and this by
the way anyone who's still out there
promoting modern monetary theory or ubi
or any of that nonsense this was a
couple times of them handing off checks
and expanding unemployment insurance by
a little bit and look at what it led to
it led to such a disruption in the
market that everyone became net
consumers and and stopped producing and
the ripple effects of that will be felt
for years
should i take out a bunch of loans right
now is what you're saying yes you should
take out loans uh credit card debt uh
anything you have a title for go to the
title loan place this is the time to buy
you got to buy in this is well so the
idea is if the recession's coming and
the value of the dollar is going to tank
then then the buying so like a car
that's worth 20 grand today is going to
be worth 40 grand in a year yeah you
take out a loan for a twenty thousand
dollar car and in a year you sell it for
forty grand you pay off the loan you
gotta free twenty grand
i mean that's some that's some uh brave
pool you're playing there but yeah i
mean well what i mean is rich guys game
right i don't know
what rich people do that is what we know
that is what rich people do except they
do it on your back right they do it with
uh fed money that just got freshly
printed and if everything goes south
then they're too big to fail this is the
point i'm making right before the
recession they know that if they borrow
a hundred thousand dollars
and then the buying power 100 000
collapses
they basically got a freebie now they
can sell whatever they bought because
the price will will spike yep the value
of the dollar goes down so you'll need
twice as many dollars to buy it so
they'll get the free money yup you know
half the buying power not with none of
the work i can imagine that that breaks
down at some point thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you